we are hanging out with the gorgeous
sweet wonderful talented alicia
silverstone
who's also an old friend and someone
that we've you know been in and around
the world together and also we're both
navigating the world of online dating
you know uh this is new to so many of us
uh we actually
so knew that we're bringing in our
resident go-to dating coach
and my love partner in crime demona
hoffman
alicia
what is your
strategy right now where are you at
what's your baseline what are you
looking for likes dislikes i
um
i don't have time i'm a busy person i
work so much i have a very full life i
love my life i love my son i just don't
have time to mess around so i'm sort of
like i just go in really open and clear
and ask really good questions so that i
can find out if we're on the same path
if if we have the same vision for our
lives if we want the same things if we
don't we're we might be really attracted
to each other but we're going to waste a
lot of time and get really hurt in the
long run you know
demona
what are your thoughts and
feelings about some of the stuff we're
saying and what should we be looking for
well alicia has a really good strategy
here actually as long as it's not so
intimidating that no one can clear the
bar right but
when i hear that she's really looking to
cut to the chase and figure out does
someone align with her goals and values
that's what so many people are afraid to
ask the tough questions because we're
afraid of getting rejected and if we
actually say what we want in the
beginning and they run away we think we
think we've done something wrong but
it's actually good if we're not aligned
in values and that's really coming out
of the pandemic what one of the biggest
trends is that people are now looking to
date based on life goals and based on
values people are really moving into
seeking substance and looking for
someone who aligns with them on a deeper
level um one thing that we have with us
which i'm very excited about and this is
so weird it's like we had a crystal ball
because the phenomenon of memes in the
last 24 hours has exploded into red
flags
it's like
we knew this was coming or something and
demona
you actually we have some red flags here
and you're going to educate us on what
are and aren't take tell me yes so i'm
going to quiz you and alicia on some of
these common red flags and you tell us
whether you think they are a red flag on
a first date or not okay this is the
most action i've had in a long time i'm
really excited because i don't have any
objectivity on how i'm doing this
so i'm so thrilled to be in this hot
seat right now it's like a pop quiz okay
are you ready alicia
totally okay the first question is
is it a red flag if their profile has a
long list of things they want in a
partner
no no
no no flags no flags no flags at all
i wish people would be more specific i
my biggest problem alicia tell me what
you feel is that uh people men
um
by the way i'm sure girls are guilty of
it too
um they're so vague and quippy and they
tell you their job is like being an
astronaut wink wink when they're clearly
not an astronaut so i don't see anybody
being specific about anything that would
be a red flag for me
i would agree with you on that if they
say what they want it shows that they've
thought about it right so many times
people tell me i'll know it when i see
it if honey if you haven't seen it you
don't know all right i have i have
another red flag quiz for you what if
their profile is only picks no text at
all
oh that's not good at all
oh the flags came out yeah that's
definitely a red flag that can be a sign
of a catfish ooh
you know catfish is someone who's not
who they say they are so they've taken
the pictures from someone else alicia
didn't you get like
someone thought you were a catfish
yes
a few years ago i tried to get on one of
the um you know dating apps and i put a
fake profile because i didn't want to
see i wasn't comfortable yet being me
and so
and then i got kicked off i got banned
and then i tried again i got the courage
up because i heard that you were on
and i heard that sharon stone was on so
i was like well if they can be on i can
be on so
so i um so i went on as myself and i
took a lot of courage to do it and then
i did it and
i had a date with someone planned and
then they the way at the day i went in
to find out about the date like where we
were meeting or whatever i'd been banned
poor guy so i've
so i got kicked off as myself too
did you ever
find the person again
no i mean i'm sure he thinks i failed
you know he's still out there i was just
gonna say
damona we might need some uh some of
your magic there
all right another red flag what if they
message you with a generic opening line
just like
hey
oh
the flags are coming out here i want to
say something i like i don't like it but
they do it all the time i mean and you
just kind of got to go with it because
they they're scared so they just write
hey and
[Laughter]
i don't i don't go like alarm i'm not
going to talk to you i just would prefer
that they have more to say than that
yeah so true so true nobody knows what
to say in that initial message but guys
come on come on you can do better than a
hay
[Music]